girl bar take John as you know we only
make one vlogbrothers video a week each
and this presents a problem because it
makes me feel that every time I make a
video that isn't totally epic making
that video that's just like here's
what's up with me this week it feels
like a waste of an opportunity to do
something important with the platform
that I have which has I think over the
years kind of changed how people
perceive the vlog where there's channel
like if you look at how our videos have
done over the last couple of months you
will see that the ones that are more
like explaining well research politics
videos those ones do a lot better in
videos that are more like travel essay
or just like talk about things and
thoughts that are more traditionally
vlogbrothers II at least in my mind this
is super not a signal for like what
direction we should be going with the
channel because like getting more views
is definitely not a path to happiness
and also not really a path to success
things are good here in blogs we got a
lot of stuff going on in our lives we
don't need views like that's not what
we're doing here but it's hard not to
kind of take it as guidance because it's
like okay people like this we should
make more of it I say no we should not
we have to mix it up because that's what
makes this channel interesting not just
for people watching but also for me it's
harder to mix it up when we have fewer
opportunities to mix it up because we
only make one video a week but we have
to only make one video a week because
lots of good reasons the primary reason
being that this community has given us
opportunities to do really important
wonderful things that we believe like I
want to make wizard school a really
amazing game I want to make VidCon a
really amazing conference I want to
encourage a new generation of video
creators and scishow and crash course
have become huge and I want them to be
bigger and better
but as scishow and crash course are now
amazingly bigger than vlogbrothers both
in views and subscribers might be
tempted to think that scishow and crash
course have become more important in my
life personally than vlogbrothers which
is not even close to the case this
channel is still by far to me the most
interesting thing that I have ever done
that I am currently doing probably that
I will ever do in my whole life all of
you who watch whether this is your first
episode or you've seen them all whether
you're an occasional viewer or on every
episode viewer having a group of people
that relies on me to always have a good
idea every week and that I can't imagine
ever letting down you are such a vital
part of the amazing life that I am
having I cannot imagine have
any of the amazing things that I've done
in the last ten years without this
obligation that I have to nerd fight
area to this community this channel has
changed many times over the years it
will continue to change as our profiles
have been elevated for lots of different
reasons it's felt less safe to be as
open and so we're more guarded now that
also might be a symptom of the YouTube
platform maturing and of like us
maturing for 10 years older now because
of that I feel a little less desire to
be silly
like if you go watch older videos
there's a lot more silliness and
likewise my music has been on the
backburner for so long that lots people
don't even know that I write music or
that I never would have without this
Chan luckily I now have snapchat for the
more silly stuff we've got almost a year
now with the dear Hank and John podcast
which is a great opportunity for more
conversational brotherly connection and
I still get to go on tour with the
perfect strangers which we'll be doing
in about a week which is just one of my
very favorite things to do in the entire
world just playing music for nerds
sometimes I am sad things must change
and I am sad things cannot be the way
that I would want them to be in a
perfect world I also love to see how
things have changed over the years and I
kind of can't wait to see where it's all
headed I hope that I never let you down
nerdfighteria I spend a lot of my time
thinking about how to do the things that
you would want me to do and I hope it's
going okay John I'll see you on Tuesday
if you want to hear about some of the
stuff that I'm up to personally that
means I can't maybe make all the vlog
with his videos I want to it that I care
a lot about and that I think are really
cool I've put another video up on Hanks
channel where I just talk about things
that are going on right now if you want
to watch that frankly I would be honored
that's all have a lovely day